oh hell yeah
so what is this so yeah some of these
are a very Australian I I'm praying to
God if there is a single person watching
this episode right now who looks at all
nine of these and goes like yeah I like
these you just name what they all are
very quickly okay so we got Simpsons
speaks and specs Adams Family
MythBusters edit native fat Pizza
Russell quotes all Aussie adventures and
Arthur okay
because half of these are from your
[ __ ] childhood yes of course they are
yeah I don't watch TV series Simpsons
why Simpsons ever say like a huge
mentioned okay so I was really debating
at first I put in Futurama but then the
more I thought about it I have more of a
childhood connection with the Simpsons
okay
um even though Futurama came out what
year did it come out like uh no not too
long yeah too long after I was like
mid-2000s I think or late 2000s okay
look it up but I feel Simpsons was that
like one cartoon that has always been
around and I have like fond childhood
memories of watching Simpsons with my
sister more than Futurama so like the
the only like I guess uh childhood
memory I have of me watching Simpsons
was before uh my my dad inevitably threw
it out he had this like old CRT TV right
and he was gonna throw it out and I was
like no no father I want it if it
doesn't still work and he's like yeah if
you like get the antenna thing on it and
you extend the [ __ ] life then it
still works and I'm like okay can I put
it in my room and so there would be
nights where like my dad would be
watching some kind of [ __ ] TV show I
didn't give a [ __ ] about and my sister
and I would go into my room and we would
take turns holding the antenna on the TV
to get good reception enough to watch
reruns of The Simpsons and so every and
because it was it played on channel 10
there were like ad breaks every like you
know 10-15 minutes so every time an ad
break came on we'll be like all right
your turn to hold the antenna and I
would just have like fond childhood
memories of that and like that would
happen after Futurama came out because
in Australia it would be a rerun of The
Simpsons and then immediately after it
would be an episode of Futurama right
right
um so it would it would kind of be like
a Simpsons Futurama combo for me but I
still remember more and vividly remember
more characters and jokes and stuff like
that from The Simpsons I consumed a lot
more Simpsons than Futurama there was
way more of it yeah and because they're
like I remember I grew up with The
Simpsons oh yeah yeah The Simpsons was
The Simpsons existed since I was born
yeah like a game every year yeah yeah
clear it came out it came out every day
but then I remember when Futurama first
started airing it was like a new thing
yeah so Simpsons has just like always
been there when did you try them come
out 1999 1999 oh okay yeah what what is
your do you have a favorite Simpsons
episode that comes to mind Simpsons Peak
Simpsons for me is the 24 short stories
about Springfield do you know that one
which one's what's the plot of that one
again it's basically just like they it's
it's basically just like a [ __ ]
Quentin Tarantino escalate just short
stories about different characters in
Springfield that all coincide with one
another and there's a lot of like movie
parodies and [ __ ] like that they parody
like Pulp Fiction multiple times and
like just like classic movies and stuff
but with Simpsons characters yeah
um and it's just a really and also like
uh we used to have like DVDs of like the
Treehouse of Horrors I love that those
are like classes
like like The Shining Parody episode of
The Simpsons is like that's Peak I love
the uh who shot Mr Burns who shot Mr
Burns and also like the the robot house
of death and stuff like that oh my God
yeah well it's like this they like
Implement like an AI like house and it's
voiced by all the characters who played
James Bond yeah oh yeah it's like it's
voiced by Pierce Brosnan yeah I think
who shot Mr Burns was how I discovered
what Cliffhangers were yeah right like
honestly I remember this is like
genuinely good stories yeah I remember
as a kid I was watching who the who shot
Mr Burns part one and then it ends right
I'm like what do you mean it's ending
what where is part two
what do you mean I have to wait I'm like
five or something right yeah but like it
the writing was so good that yeah you
know you got a [ __ ] child yeah and
and I think as well like I had a really
good because like obviously Simpsons
started way before any of us were born
yeah and so like a lot of the The
Simpsons that we saw on that shitty CR
TV were reruns of the older Seasons
which anyone who's watched enough
Simpsons will agree with Peak Simpsons
right yeah exactly um when did you stop
watching The Simpsons when did you all
start watching The Simpson when I stop
watching TV yeah pretty much focus on in
the UK right
on Sky yeah paid uh broadcasting which
my dad bought because he wanted football
matches yeah so it was like oh we'll buy
this and then the only reason that you
know the wife won't get angry at me so
it's for the family because we've got
other channels as well right so we had
we had that and um he used to play four
episodes uh a day from six to eight pm
damn so every single day after school
just chill in the living room do
whatever I need to do and just watch
four episodes of The Simpsons yeah yeah
a single day I remember I think it was
like on weekends they would do like
three or four episode runs this is crazy
yeah it was great yeah I could I can
remember the exact moment for me that
the Simpsons died in my mind it was
actually like The Simpsons Movie I think
oh wow
I remember like oh okay so wow Simpson's
got a movie that's a big [ __ ] deal I
haven't like at that point I hadn't like
watched you know I grew up with The
Simpsons but I wasn't like regularly
watching you don't realize that like
season like nine or ten is [ __ ] yeah
yeah you're just like oh this is funny
he
and then I remember like people [ __ ]
losing it over [ __ ] spider pig or
something oh my God I hated that and I'm
just like what
this isn't funny why is yeah that was
definitely the least funniest part of
The Simpsons that was like there were
many not funny parts of this yeah that
was like I remember back when that came
out people like quoting it I'm like this
is the pickle Rick of my time you know
it literally was yeah I was just like
why are people quoting spider pig it's
not even try to pick Ransom pickle Ricky
dude I I [ __ ] love especially like
when we were probably getting in
Simpsons when all the best Simpsons
games were out yeah like hit and run on
one of the arcades the arcade ones
yeah oh my God that was a [ __ ] coin
guzzler that was Peak Simpsons right but
yeah I mean Simpson's great I mean yeah
what the [ __ ] is specs and specs yeah
specs and specs is a TV show that sounds
Australia it looks like a kid's show
it's a quiz show um quiz show it's a
music question it's like a gay pride
show no no no they just happen to have a
rainbow a rainbow's a dope it's named
after I think a uh uh a Beach Boys song
I think right but basically it's this
kind of it's kind finally imagine like
Qi right but yeah except all of the
questions and all of the guests are the
musicians okay this is right up your ass
yeah and obviously you know I'm a
[ __ ] music nerd right so it's like
that show was really cool because not
only would they get really cool
musicians on as guests but they also
like it was hosted by an Australian
comedian
um called Adam Hills
um and he had you know in any in each
team there would be like different kinds
of you know music themed like quizzes
and like that would also break into like
a talk show where they would like talk
about guests and stuff like that I think
one of my one of the weirdest segments
that they had was they had this quiz
early on in specs and specs called
musician or serial killer
and they'll basically what they would do
is they would show a black and white
picture and just by looking at the
picture of the person it's like a mug
shot like you would have to guess is
this a musician or a serial killer
that's also wow yeah and a lot of the
times I and and as a kid I watch that
and you know you'd play along obviously
because you you know there's no [ __ ]
prior knowledge or anything this is
before True Crime [ __ ] was a thing right
yeah yeah and so like it was really
weird that I swear the more someone
looked like a serial killer the more
likely they were more likely they were a
musician and vice versa I believe it
yeah and so there was stuff like that
there was another one where it was like
um they took song lyrics put them
through Google translate it's like some
Asian language and then translated it
back in English and then they would read
that out and you'd have to guess what
the song is and so like it was just like
really cool ideas for quizzes that's a
great idea for enough dark question
honestly I like him Honestly though like
I came up with like you know I came up
with so many like quiz ideas and stuff
like that for my videos through shows
like this yeah because it was just like
really interesting and fun ways where
you could kind of oh another one where
was like there was like an exercise bike
that was connected to a vinyl player
like a vinyl record player right and you
had to Pedal the bike at a certain speed
for the song to be able to play oh
that's cool you have to quickly guess
yeah yeah what the song is for example
it's just stuff like that sounds good
yeah it's a really really good show Even
if you have no idea about music just the
fact that it's like hosted by a comedian
who's really funny has a lot of really
cool musical guests and just like the
quiz segments are just really creative
yeah which is like really really good
show
um and then I guess top right is the
only Japanese show I put in God you know
Sky basically every American uh you know
like uh punishment game remake remake
came from this okay so Silent Library is
one of the most famous ones these guys
came up with the first
um another one would explain what silent
libraries is Silent Library I guess so
basically everyone yeah Silent Library
basically is just again these guys
started first but basically you would go
into a public library sit around a desk
and then you would hand out uh like
cards you'd flip them over one person
would get the punishment and then they
would have to do a punishment but react
yeah silently yeah and these punishments
in this show were [ __ ] brutal I mean
Japanese TV shows is a big history yeah
reputation for being yeah like Takeshi's
Castle is another show that I thought
about putting that in here but he
definitely pushed the line in terms of
like what you can get away with it some
of the things that they did on this show
were like actual torture yeah like it's
crazy like uh one segment that they did
was um 24 hour no reaction uh pie face
challenge where basically one of the
comedians in this group would live in
this like mock house and the entire time
for 24 hours the rest of the cast are
throwing like pies at his face and he's
not allowed to react for 24 hours what
yeah it's just [ __ ] like that it's just
being Pi boarded you're being High
borders for 24 hours straight insane
yeah it's it's insane another one was
like 24 hour tag so that would be inside
of a gymnasium and then randomly a dude
would pop up and if you got tagged by
them then you'd have to get punished for
24 hours it's just crazy I noticed in
Japanese TV when you've done your time
so to say you've done the the brutal
stuff and done all the you've put
yourself out there a bunch you get to be
the react Andy yeah when you become the
show you become royalty in Japan's
comedy scene you get to react yep that's
that because that's that's who the big
dogs are yeah because they're on
everything every big Celebrity Face you
see yeah it's always the [ __ ]
in the corner of the screen they're all
the comedians that you see just in the
react corner of the screen they started
off doing [ __ ] like yeah so it's like
we've done our time
with the work their way off the system
man it's like hunting games and maybe
you get a successful
exactly but like on like honestly if
you're a YouTuber just watch the
episodes of Goku not sky and it's just a
treasure
oh yeah I mean that guy is the [ __ ]
oh yeah
but uh yeah so that's uh that's like one
of my favorite Japanese shows going on I
also learn a lot of Japanese watching
that show as a child I believe it yeah